so my name is John visa desu I'm a
product manager at Google and I work a
lot on how enterprise customers connect
to our cloud infrastructure and today's
talk is going to be exactly about that
well we're gonna be covering is a little
bit about and you're gonna hear this
throughout the whole week I'm gonna talk
a little bit about the Google
infrastructure what we how you connect
to us today and then talk a little bit
about how you connect to us tomorrow or
soon talk a little bit about
architectures deployment architectures
and how you can use our cloud networking
to build enterprise networks that extend
out to the cloud something about how we
monitor these systems what we do around
monitoring some discussion about how you
can get better application performance
when you come to cloud and finally a
little bit about the pricing of all this
stuff so infrastructure and you know if
you go to about half of the sessions of
this conference you're gonna see a
picture something like this and what
this is trying to point out is where are
all the cloud data centers when you
build an enterprise network you have
cloud data centers as well
and all right I should say you have data
centers this is saying we're Google's
data centers are and the ones in green
are showing the ones that are available
today and all the ones in blue are data
centers that are in the process of being
built out the numbers tell you how many
zones each one of those data centers has
and as you can see what we're trying to
do is cover the globe with data centers
that are close to customers because
millisecond closeness means application
performance so it's really important to
get that level of connectivity the other
thing that we have and if I take away
all the cloud data centers what pops out
is all these little lines this is
Google's backbone this is what we have
been spending years and years on
building predominantly it was to service
the applications that Google's known for
you know search and YouTube and Gmail
and all those
what we're doing with our cloud
networking infrastructure is giving you
access to all of this
now you don't see it because it's hidden
under the covers but your application
data runs over this infrastructure and
it's an infrastructure that Google
continues to build on so this is what it
looks like today if you see this little
there's this thing that sits 2018
that's a fiber cable that we're dropping
from somewhere important in the Oregon
area to somewhere in Japan and we're
gonna drop in you know a little over a
hundred terabytes of infrastructure
there to give you more capacity to
originally just to give Google more
capacity but in short it's also to give
our customers more capacity as you grow
so you know we're expanding you know
didn't summary Google cloud is an
expanding platform it's expanding to
cover give you global footprint a
footprint that's close to your customers
that gives you high availability local
availability the ability to take VMs and
get them closer to your customers and
continue to drive the scale that you
guys are driving us to build so today
there are a number of ways to connect to
this infrastructure the first one is
something what we call direct peering
this is where you have a private ASN or
sorry a public ASN and you're connecting
to our infrastructure at one of our
points of presence I'll go into where
our points of presence are in just a
second this is public peering so when
you do that you get all of Google's
routing table and you expose your
routing table to us another way to do
that is through a carrier interconnect
and that's where you go through you know
carriers that you know and love and
connect to us through their
infrastructure to us and finally if you
do if you can't do either one of these
two or you have a place where you know
you don't have a lot of capacity you
don't need a lot of capacity you can
connect to us using a VPN tunnel so I'll
go into some detail about that as well
so our cloud interconnects you know
first of all when you go through this
direct peering links you do get a
dedicated link that means you have he
said I wouldn't say enhance security but
you're just going over a cross connect
in a colocation facility so it's in a
protected physically protected
environment and you know from a
performance standpoint you're getting
carrier level SLA s you're getting
locations in 70 locations in 33
countries so it's a place where you can
get closer to us and get better
performance out of it and finally a lot
of customers use these methods for the
last reason which is there's lower
egress costs when you come and meet us
versus when we have to carry your
traffic to you
and finally with those systems you get
access to the whole set of Google
properties so if you're an enterprise
customer who's rolling out G suite and
you want to have a close connection that
doesn't go over the Internet these are
great solutions for you unfortunately a
lot of the customers what you really
need is a extend your private network
into cloud and today the way you do that
is with our IPSec VPN solution so all
right IPSec VPN solution is a
virtualized solution that runs in the
cloud it's a scale-out VPN so each
tunnel starts at about 3 gigabits per
second but you can scale that out based
on deploying more infrastructure on top
of that and what it does is it lets you
take your RFC 1918 space your private
address space and extend it to cloud and
we do that with couple entities here
there's a cloud router and a VPN gateway
VPN gateway of quartz terminates your
IPSec sessions and the cloud router
gives you the BGP a reach ability of
everything in your cloud I'm gonna make
one comment on cloud router because I'm
gonna use this throughout the rest of
the presentation I want you guys to
understand what does the cloud router do
yes it is a BGP endpoint but that's all
it is is the control plane of our
routing infrastructure so when you
terminate a BGP session on the cloud
router what it does is it programs the
routes into our Sdn infrastructure if
you I don't know if you've ever read
about something called Andromeda
Andromeda is Google's Sdn network
architecture there's some great
presentations on it I'm not going to
cover that here there is actually some
presentations online that go into a lot
of detail there but cloud router is not
the typical you know juniper or cisco
router that all the packets go through
it it just programs the it's the control
plane that programs the data plane so
packets don't go through that so it
doesn't we don't need a scale out router
it's a scale out network so I just
wanted to cover that before I use it in
other contexts and you guys understand
what the cloud router do when you scale
out a VPN - if you need more than three
gigabits per second you can use multiple
tunnels and use ecmp across those
tunnels to get greater capacity and we
have customers doing that today to drive
tens of gigs of traffic into their cloud
infrastructure but that seems a little
bit yesterday so what we're doing today
is announcing the some products that are
coming out later on this year actually
later on this quarter that will allow
you to extend that using more
traditional networking architectures
other than VPN so specifically we're
announcing two products one is called
private interconnect another was called
partner interconnect both of these
techniques allow you to extend your RFC
1918 address space from your premise to
the cloud with the private interconnect
this is where you meet us in one of our
colocation facilities and you extend a
cross connect from your routed
infrastructure to our edge
and with partner interconnect is where
you go using a carrier and they can
offer you a sub rate interface or
actually a full 10 gig interface to our
cloud infrastructure so private
interconnect this is where an enterprise
customer comes to Google and partner
interconnect is where an enterprise
customer goes to a carrier and then
comes to Google again the goal here is
to extend your network to our network
using your private address space into
Google's in your private address space
in the Google cloud and it doesn't
require the use of any VPN devices and
uses standard routing as I'll go into in
just a second so more pictorial your
pictorial view with private interconnect
there's the Google peering edge and
there's your peering router and your
connecting to us in a colocation
facility that means your network is
connecting to your compute instances in
the cloud and with partner interconnect
you're coming through a service provider
from your router to their infrastructure
into the Google cloud this as in the
previous diagram these are all layer 2
connections and I'll talked about how
you do the layer 3 extension in just a
second
there are carriers that offer you a
service like in Metro II kind of a
service where they offer you an Ethernet
connection and you don't have to worry
about the routing infrastructure so
there are two methods that carriers
offer one where you have to deal with
DGP and another one where you don't have
to deal with BGP so where do you connect
to us shortly when we come out with the
product you'll be able to connect us
where all these green areas are and over
the course of 2017 we'll be lighting up
a lot of these areas in blue these are
points of presence that Google has
across the globe so what is a point of
presence for instance in Chicago were
actually in two locations in Chicago
were in coresight and in Equinix
in Frankfurt we're in four locations in
Frankfurt so we say that you're we have
a metro availability what we're doing is
actually offer you in a number of
connections in that metro and in each
one of those connections we offer
multiple no shared fate path paths to a
Google infrastructure so if for instance
if you come into course site in Chicago
what you'll see is there are two
locations that you can connect to us in
Chicago in course site what we call zone
1 and zone 2 and there's no shared fate
between the two of them so if you're
building a highly reliable network you
probably want to connect in zone 1 and
zone 2
I'll go with the high availability and
architectures for high availability
later on in this slide deck so in
general you know it doesn't matter where
you connect to us in that Metro you're
connecting into the Google
infrastructure but in multiple sites in
any one Metro so a little some comments
ok you know this is all well and good
but what do I have to do a couple things
this is all single mode fiber we support
LACP for link bonding so we offer 10 gig
interfaces you can link bond across
multiple 10 gig interfaces to go up from
10 gig up to 80 and even more if you go
for more please come and talk to us
because there's better ways of doing
that you have to support a link local
address so if you're doing the private
solution you have to have a link local
address on your router you have to have
a private ASN that you've exchanged with
us 802 1q VLAN tagging and that's how
we'll do traffic separation I'll go into
the details about traffic separation in
just a bit and this is all using ipv4
link-local addresses so a little bit
more detail so link local address
between your router and the router you
connect to is actually the cloud router
so that we talked about earlier this is
where your virtual connection ends up
being is on your cloud router in your
project so in that project you can then
connect to VM instances
and you're taking your private address
space you're going over a layer to
connection to the Google cloud
infrastructure and to your project
instances running in the Google cloud so
if you're in multiple regions you'd have
a cloud router in one region a cloud
router in another region and then you'd
have VLAN tags going between both of
them so this shows one VLAN tag going to
one region and another VLAN tag would go
to another region all those instances
can talk to each other over the Google
cloud background that's all well and
good but let's get better so we're
announcing a feature to cloud router
called global routing what global
routing does is why should I you know if
I use BGP I should be able to advertise
region 2 out of region 1 so now I only
have two Devoy to deploy one cloud
router that means I only have to peer
with Google in one location and now you
have access to our whole infrastructure
remember and this is something that
maybe we don't drill into you guys
enough is that the network that you have
in a cloud project is a network that
spans the globe and this is what I'm
showing here is that even though you're
connecting in one region you have
connectivity to all the regions that you
have projects your project has VMs in so
that means you get access to that
infrastructure I showed in earlier
slides and if you're a multinational
company that wants to for instance do
web serving out to you know people all
over the globe you only really need one
connected one connection to us and that
gives you access to infrastructure
across across the globe now there are
customers that have actually most
customers have multiple projects so you
might have a dev project you might have
your release project you don't want the
two networks to meet that would be a
very bad thing it gives you that
of cross-pollination of information and
you know hackers can get through one
network into the other and most
customers want to keep their production
network separate from your development
network so what you do is you can have a
project with a cloud router here and
another project with a cloud Rider here
there's VLAN tagging that separates the
traffic between those two projects and
on your side you would do brf's to
separate the traffic on your enterprise
network so this gives you one link into
Google but multiple projects using that
link and having traffic separation
across those multiple projects the other
thing actually there's a talk this
afternoon at 4 o'clock that's gonna go
into a lot of detail on EXPN which is
our cross project networking solution
also known as a shared VPC so what is a
shared VPC in google's world what
happens is that you have a host project
and you have service projects you're
networking for those service projects
ends up in the host project so this is
where you virtually connect to the
Google cloud in that project this is
where all your network resources are
these are where your firewall policies
can live and what that lets you do is
have a separation of concerns between
the folks that are worried about
security and networking and those that
are worried about development so this
lets you share a resource like a network
connect connection to multiple projects
without those projects really needing to
know about the physical infrastructure
of building a network so you can monitor
you can have one set of people
monitoring your network infrastructure
and another set of people doing all the
production deployments of your VMs and
all of that so you have that separation
of concerns you have that separation of
management responsibilities and that
extends to the iam roles that are
associated with these hosts and service
projects again this afternoon there's
going to be a presentation that goes
into a lot more technical detail about a
shared VPC
and how you can use it in your projects
so as I said we were gonna talk a little
bit about high availability when you
deploy network infrastructure anywhere
you're going to want to do multiple
links into our infrastructure one of the
reasons is that we can't support an SLA
for one single connection we do
maintenance on all this infrastructure
and when we do maintenance we would take
your network out which is not a nice
thing so what we suggest doing is in one
colocation facility have multiple links
that gives you the ability to have
redundancy and we give you the benefit
of having no shared fate between those
two lengths but in addition to that and
a lot of customers want to go this route
is that you want to do more than that
you want to have multiple connections in
multiple regions and the reason you want
to do that is because you want to deal
with failover you know Metro level
failover if your infrastructure in a
Metro fails you can fail over to another
metro area so now you have two routers
well we've also done in these two
routers is we've built the ability to
use BGP the way it's meant to be used so
you can have different route preferences
in each one of those routers so let's
say this facility is in London and this
facilities of the Bay Area in San
Francisco if you get a cable cut here in
London your traffic off your network
would end up in San Francisco because
the BGP route preferences would tell you
that's what you want to do you'd see
that there was a disconnect connectivity
to your London facility and you'd route
your traffic to another facility
so this gives you what we're doing is
starting to extend the cloud router the
network infrastructure to look more like
a traditional enterprise network with
the same level of redundancy the same
level of failover the same way of doing
all these things that you do in a you
know large Multi multi region
multi-country enterprise network oh one
other one last thing on this also when
you think about I used to do a lot of
work with telcos and telcos are all
about it has to be 5/9 and they're
starting to think about 6/9 so with this
kind of an infrastructure you start
building that level of failover that
level of SLA by multiplying the number
of connections you have so with a
description if you if you were to build
a network that looks something like this
you'd be able to build a network that
had a five nines reliability a number of
customers have come to us and said yeah
you know that's private address space is
really good but what I really want to do
is I have some public address space and
I would like to backup that public
address space with infrastructure in the
cloud and there's a way to do that in
GCP the first thing you do is at the VM
level you detach an IP address to each
one of those VM so you're taking that
public IP address and attaching it at
the operating system level of the VM the
second thing you do is you'd with
another feature that's coming out
shortly is you'd be able to change the
route that is being advertised today the
cloud router advertises in a very static
way what routes are available we're
adding a feature called flexible routing
that allow you to specify which wraps
you to advertise a reason you'd want to
do this is for instance you may have a
production network that you're not ready
to go and expose to the whole world that
you want to have it already so you want
the routing infrastructure ready you'll
be able to flip a bit on that network
and then it'll start to be advertised
off the cloud router so a way to
predictably release routes out to your
on-premise infrastructure so that's a
feature that's coming out so um in cloud
router you'd add the prefixes for those
public IPs that you want to advertise
over bgp
then you'd add a static route from the
private IP because these VM instances
will have a Google private IP and you
need to know how to get the reverse
traffic back so you'd rather put a
static route taking that private IP to
the public IP of the VM sorry from the
public IP to the private IP of the VM
and finally you'd set up your router so
that advertises those prefixes to the
rest of the world and that that is a
method for getting public IP s into the
Google infrastructure that are your own
public eyepiece because today the only
way you can use the public IP is if you
take something out of our range so for
monitoring so now we've given you a link
to our infrastructure and you've decided
to provision 10-gig and you have no idea
how much of that link you're using so
they'll be mum this is a mock-up of the
user interface that you'd see in the
cloud console and we'll do things like
link utilization drops items like that
it will also give you you know suggest
that you get a ping endpoints so you can
measure round-trip times and monitor
that as well and all of these statistics
will be available in stock driver so you
can actually extract them and put them
into your own console so you don't have
to go to the Google console to get all
this data you can actually get it out
and use it on your own another thing
we're changing as you know we've we've
done some fundamental changes in how you
interconnect to the Google
infrastructure and doing fundamental
changes means you probably fundamentally
want to change the way we describe that
in the cloud console so today we're
interconnected as you see there's
something called VPN that's going to
change so the interconnect and that will
subsume VPN and private and partner
interconnect so you'd have one place to
go in our user interface to control
those interconnect methods into the
cloud
so now you've moved your application to
the cloud you've connected to us in a
variety of areas it's still different
it's not your data center right it's not
the rack of machines that's down the
hall and what we found is that customers
have a problem their applications have
problems with this because we've changed
fundamentally we've changed some of the
network some of the basic networking
parameters that applications are used to
and what that big change we've done is
we've changed the latency between your
front and the application and the back
end whether it be a database server
whether it be some other REST API that
that application is using and those
changes mean that you may want to think
about changing the way the application
behaves so I'm going to go into some
details about how you can change the
application to make sure that you're
getting the most of our network and it
really has to do about something called
the bandwidth delay product and let me
go into a little bit about why what this
is so if you look at typical cloud
latencies and I'm throwing showing you
three Google regions that we have and
the average latency teach one of those
regions from our pop locations so if you
have an instance running in our US
central region and you connect to us at
the closest place you can connect to
that US central region you're still
about 10 milliseconds away from those
VMs in u.s. East it's about 10 to 25
milliseconds and finally in Europe
because it's a smaller place it's about
five to seven milliseconds that's
different and the difference is profound
because what you'll see and now I'm
gonna go into a little bit of details
about how TCP works if you think about
it what TCP does is it sends a bunch of
data down the pipe right and it sends a
Windows worth of data down the pipe when
you're in the same data center your
application and the backend are running
in the same data center
the time it takes to send that is you
know fairly quick right well it's the
time to take regardless of where you're
at the time it takes the Senate is still
about the same what's very different is
how long it takes to acknowledge that
data because your data goes down the
pipe has to get to its destination
before an acknowledgement can come back
and on a network that is less than a
millisecond in delay this time is very
short but as you get to even like even
short delays like seven milliseconds if
you use the default settings in a TCP
kernel you're gonna get really bad
performance and I get a lot of calls
from customers saying you know I
connected to you I have these big pipes
to you and I still get really lousy
performance why and they're forgetting
one thing is I need to change the TCP DP
behavior to take advantage of the well
not take advantage to remediate the
issues you have with this milliseconds
of latency that you've added to your
application and the way you do that is
by increasing the advertised window in
your TCP session so rather than
advertising in the default window you
want to extend that window so that you
can send more data to the remote site
now this doesn't help applications that
you know especially HTTP applications
that are doing small transactions all
the time but it really affects
applications that are trying to move
lots of data and that's where more often
than not you complain about slowness
you're doing an upload into GC a GCS
cloud bucket you're you know taking you
know the movie you just finished
rendering and downloading it doing those
kinds of things can take a long time if
you don't take into account the did
light bandwidth product and the way to
do that is by increasing the window size
and when you increase the window size
what happens is that you send more data
and you acknowledge more data at the
same time meaning you can keep the pipe
full so if you're getting 10 gigabit
pipeline pipes to us you really want to
keep the 10 gigabits full especially if
you're doing these large data
transfers so just some notes on one last
note on this subject is that many of the
TCP Colonels already set up this way and
the reason I bring this up is because if
you do see that it's a good way to go
check this and if you you know do a
Wikipedia search on delay bandwidth
product there's tons of articles that go
into how you'd go and look at these
features and how you calculate all these
things so let's talk briefly about
pricing of the solution because everyone
wants to know how much they're gonna
spend right so with our public item
right now it's when you're doing direct
peering with us we don't charge you to
direct pair with us and we give you some
benefits on the cost of egress so you
get a benefit in price on the cost of
egress with VPN you're paying for the
VPN gateway and that's roughly about
five dollars a month for every three
roughly three gigabits of large packet
data with the new solution that we're
coming up with private interconnect it's
a twenty five hundred dollar charge for
the port that you get we give you and
there's egress costs on top of that with
a partner connection there's a lot of
charges and depending on how you connect
with a partner we start at the partner
access pricing so whatever they charge
you to connect to us and then there's a
sliding scale depending on how much data
you're pumping into Google on our end as
well so this gives you a sense of what
the pricing is of those solutions so I'm
almost finished so how do you learn more
you know if you're really interested in
this please talk to your sales folks
whoever your sales contact is at Google
so that they can help you get into our
team possibly come part of the Alpha and
be aware of when the beta of this
solution comes out the other area where
you can help a lot is
somewhere this there she is there's one
of my colleagues in an orange t-shirt
back there and they're running a UX lab
down on the first floor so if you're
interested in helping us help you with a
great user interface they're more than
happy and more than willing to listen to
you guys and you know get you involved
in studies about how we do UX
development at Google so that we can
give you great user interfaces and
getting great solutions back and finally
there are a number of sessions that
cover a number of aspects of networking
unfortunately one of them is actually
happening right now that's two doors
down but I want to bring this up all
these sessions are recorded so if you
miss a session here you'll be able to
see at a later time so I want to
highlight some of these sessions that
are happening throughout the course of
the next three days
and I finally I end up with one on
Friday where were we talking about third
party solutions to networking today
check point for instance on announced
there v SEC v SEC firewall so
next-generation firewalls for for GCP
we'll be talking about that and we'll be
talking about other SSL VPN about load
balancers and other solutions for
enterprise networking in the cloud
you